[Music]
my name is Tony Gemignani I'm a 12-time
world to champion today I'm gonna show
you how to make some amazing so the
older the dough the better I'm looking
for our dough that I made today and use
it in 24 hours 36 hours even 48 hours if
you could the longer you let that you
see the less simple shirt content that's
in that dough if you're cooking in your
home oven and it's between 500 degrees
and 600 degrees always add a Browning
agent to your recipe these type of
ingredients will help your bill Brown
quicker and you'll have a much better
pizza what I'm looking for
great mozzarella I look for a whole milk
mozzarella whole milk mozzarella has a
higher butter fat it'll Brown less in
your oven have a better stretch and be
full of flavor
you always want to make a pizza look
beautiful so you don't want to just make
it beautiful and then cut it up and mess
it up you actually want to cut that
pizza first and then beautify it in the
pizza business the ingredients usually
go on after the bake you have a much
prettier pizza you have a much stronger
pizza and all around just much better
tasty pizza when it comes to fresh beef
I always think that's always a finishing
oh oh yes
[Music]
[Music]